so anyway we uh everybody's freaking out
because we're a minute late hey come on
it's because there's a delay I pressed
the live button the moment it comes up
and then YouTube has like a minute delay
yeah so we're here yeah we're good yeah
we're here people people are present a
finish yet what up everybody yeah thanks
for worrying about us appreciate but
we're here tired we've been making our
own bread yeah because because you know
we're under a render martial law
it's good bread jackboot people's
drummers marching on the street I'm just
kidding we're making a hardtack I love
that we have a skate park in our
backyard what kind of do we have
concrete okay I mean we have concrete in
the backyard we put some skate stuff we
can skate we go to a mini ramp yeah I
know but a medium ramp that's pretty
good
not really no it's mini dude that's so
small okay right it'll be better if it's
not about four and a half feet or five
feet and it's sixteen sixteen foot
across that's pretty yeah pretty long
yep it's great yeah we got our so so for
all of you that are dealing with the
current apocalypse yeah I know that
there's probably I don't I wouldn't know
how to bet but I bet a lot of people
don't live in cities that's true I'd be
willing to bet you know most of the
people are not gonna live I don't know
maybe I'm wrong I could not imagine
living in Chicago or New York right now
I'm so happy I'm gone from New York at
least in Chicago they still have back
you know now the epicenter of the u.s.
coronaviruses Oh totally comes bringing
in hospital ships yeah it's cool it's
surrounded by water so smart yeah but
they're not for a coronavirus what
they're served a hundred regular people
right yeah so yeah that makes sense
actually
so people with coronavirus can go to the
hospitals and not infect it to regular
folks yeah like it that makes sense yeah
so we know so our lead story here which
has a lot of people concerned
disconcerted shocking moment exhausted
Dutch Health Minister collapses in
Parliament due to fatigue from intense
weeks fighting coronavirus crisis now I
know you can't write you know you can
choose to trust the official statement
or you can choose to question government
officials who have been repeatedly
trying to downplay this and even in my
opinion even the ones that are saying
like no it is a bigger deal than we
realize they're still downplaying it
yeah so there's another story right now
about Tucker Carlson who used that Fox
News host you know everybody knows we as
I guess and apparently he was talking to
somebody in intelligence who said China
was lying about everything and this is
really really bad so he actually went
down and talked to Trump and told him
like you have to get on this and so I I
guess the story is Trump just doesn't
trust the media and I don't disagree do
you know I really understand why right
I'm not who does the media do you trust
the media no no I know I don't I don't
there was a there this is hilarious
there was a research study done by
Edelman and they found that of like 15
different criteria the the most trusted
individuals on the krona virus are
health scientists makes sense the least
trusted journalists journalists scored
less than someone like me that means you
could walk up to a stranger on the
street he could be like so I heard
there's a virus I need back really and
if a journalist how do they been I don't
know about that
trust now I'll tell you what what
they're gonna start saying in the media
it's Trump's fault for attacking the
press it's like no dude yeah it's your
fault for putting up yes so here's what
I bring that US has just gotten worse
and worse well the reason the reason I
bring this up is so we actually have the
video let's let me play the video for
everybody first this is bno newsroom and
let's just let's just just play it so
you can see all right there he is right
there and then boom he's goes down no
when people rush over to help pick him
up so here's here's the thing here's the
thing here's the thing here's the thing
why don't you tell me what the thing
will tell you about the thing I really
want to know we've had a series of
videos of people collapsing in the
street and for the longest time we've
had tons of people saying no no no it's
not it's not coronavirus rated at all
and then it's like people wearing masks
in China I'm falling down face-first you
know there's one video it's creepy man
someone just kills just boom right in
the ground and blood that's coming out
people are making out there's there's
one video or someone like struggles and
then falls and tries to stop themselves
we had the same videos come on
Ron and then we had one dude in Queens
Queens right I remember that now we
don't know these were all coronavirus
true but I gotta say isn't there like an
Occam's razor on this one you have a
global pandemic a respiratory illness
that causes people to become faint and
have shortness of breath and then people
pass out I mean that two plus two equals
four right right so when you see a video
of this dutch health healthcare minister
you can just go by what they're saying
no no no he's just fatigued he's tired
or is this really something I mean
that's what they're saying but I don't
think so do you think it was he was sick
yeah yeah I think so
I mean it's all over Europe yeah he was
saying that he's just been tired and
fatigued and that's and that's possible
too I could be true be true he collapsed
yeah that wasn't like I feel home and
I'm faint I got it like yes I feel like
if he really was fatigued he would have
just you know sat down like you'd get to
the point where like I need to sit down
that looked like uncontrolled so maybe
look maybe he's not taking his vitamins
he might maybe he's got a bad diet
people that are that I mean working that
hard first off that's we do need people
that are working crazy but you're
basically lowering your immune system so
yeah do contract it you're gonna get hit
crazy good point man so if if this isn't
the corona virus and he's that weak
right now if he comes in contact with
anybody
this too is dead well come on know about
dead hey you're right I I don't know for
certain no I'll be in the hospital but
he's obviously an older gentleman he's
56 yeah yeah you know it's like if he's
if he's that weak that he's passing out
and while standing and working so hears
that he's susceptible man here's what he
said he said quote I was feeling faint
from fatigue and intense weeks I am
feeling better now I am going home now
to rest this evening so I can return
tomorrow to fight the corona crisis he
said in a message on social media
Bruins is a top government health
official in the Netherlands where the
number of confirmed cases of the corona
virus rose by 346 on Wednesday to 2050
one with 58 deaths the country's
National Institute for Health said so
look at Italy man yeah four hundred and
seventy five deaths in
one day do New York City just doubled
theirs as well doubled their deaths
really what's the what's the number
doubled to 1871 that's the total
reported cases what about the deaths not
deaths sorry sorry yeah I think the
deaths in New York City is only like 10
or 6 dude when MSNBC came out and that
now I guess they've done like multiple
segments where at least at least Joe
Scarborough being like we must support
the president that's me being like whoa
what's happening dude these people are
scared yeah if they're gonna come out
and support Trump but what he was what
Scarborough was saying is that the worst
case estimates are two million dead more
than you know world war two Korea
Vietnam combined or something like that
yeah dude that's that's why people are
freaking out so anyway check this out
I've got another video this is a video
from Wuhan hospital patient collapses on
the ground and look this is a verified
is his Chinese Austrian artist hunted by
the Chinese I don't know who this person
is but there are verified Twitter users
so they've you know I don't know if that
necessarily means they're more credible
or less because yeah journalists you
know I mean but what what you know what
am I supposed to think when I see a
bunch of wearing masks in the hospital
and someone passes out and we're talking
about a respiratory illness now the
funny thing about this is that actually
pulled up there was a bunch of videos
from Snopes okay and I'm actually you
know they're criticizing the president
because he was downplaying this okay but
Snopes and other fact-checking outlets
were really really really downplaying
this whenever somebody would say
something like this like check this out
wuhan pneumonia they'd say no no no fake
news fake news ignore it all the World
Health Organization tweeted mid-january
new report new study from China shows
that the corona virus can't be
transmitted person-to-person
the and the tweet still live Wow yeah
man and they wanna they want us to
believe them now here's here's what gets
really really crazy oh my god this story
really blew my mind
Tucker Carlson says Trump allies wanted
to pretend coronavirus wasn't happening
went tomorrow logo to warn the president
now that's not what I find shocking I
think it's a cool story
good for you Tucker you know going and
getting the job done but what's crazy is
that apparently Tucker was talking to
somebody who worked in intelligence
who told them that China was lying took
us out Karlsson said he was alerted to
the danger of the new coronavirus after
speaking to to a non-partisan figure in
the US government with access to
intelligence who claimed that the
Chinese authorities were not being
transparent about the outbreak which
really got my attention carlson talked
about the outbreak in his monologue on
his show on february 3rd but attention
at the time was focused on the Iowa
caucuses and that when people see
everything through an ideological lens
it's very hard to get to tell a
straightforward story man this was very
very early yeah good on Tucker calling
this out but what what is disconcerting
to me is that he this story basically
confirms look I know everyone basically
speculates China's lying yeah yeah wait
like that we mean especially we know but
when the one the World Health
Organization is like China says we're
good then it's like and now here we are
and now it's a global pendant we're not
good but this just came out people in
intelligence in the US government knew
yeah they knew so apparently what ended
up happening was Trump is hearing from
all of these you know he's got he's got
yes men around him and he's got people
who just don't trust the media so
they're like nananana ignore this and a
lot of fox personalities were saying the
same thing you know incorrectly but
that's the big challenge when you have
like you said an ideological lens you
have all these people you know in media
who just lie all the time you know so
who's gonna believe it I mean my initial
reaction when I saw this in China very
early like in January was mmm yeah like
what's gonna be and then a week later I
was like whoa like probably around the
same time as Tucker and I was like this
is getting serious yeah so you have the
people in the US government I don't know
what advice they were giving to Trump
but he wasn't listening you know he's
like I don't believe it I'm not gonna
buy it people are trying to you know
mess with me yeah but if now they're
saying things like a week at work we got
good news China is saying the cases are
going down you've got to be out of your
mind so way to believe someone believes
something coming out China what what
what what is this believe anyway why
would anyone in their right mind believe
them now no it doesn't make any sense
but this story is to me it gives some
confirmation that US government knows
that China's been lying the whole time
so if anyone in the government now comes
out and says you know China
you know get the numbers down we're
seeing the end of this I'm gonna be like
not you're lying yeah you're lying we
got the story right here man well this
was in February though no no no right so
this is when he was being told mm-hmm so
this is this is the story just comes
just came out and Tucker said someone
told him China was not being transparent
about what's going on I have no reason
to believe they're they're transparent
now or ever have been oh yeah dude oh
come on like literally everything out of
China is a lie yeah they steal our IP
they've they've manipulated their
currency to steal our manufacturing
they're just underhanded you know their
government it's funny whenever you try
and criticize governments you get
bombard with people calling you racist
it's like dude China's at the most
racist country on the planet man spare
me I'm not interested yeah so yeah
honestly I feel bad for like the
citizens yeah like the normal everyday
people that but they don't know man I
yeah I mean look I'm not an expert on
China like I get hit up by a ton of
people in the comments saying like you
check out these channels mhm yeah that's
but you know I've seen some of them and
for sure my understanding is you know
cuz I've talked to a few people who are
experts in the region some journalists
and they were saying that they're low
income uneducated you know people who
just go about their daily lives
and they're just kind of like cogs in
the machine they don't they're not super
concerned for the most part there are a
lot of people who are yeah but a lot of
regular people are just like let me
alone
and so that the government does their
thing and as long as you don't rock the
boat you just do your thing and you live
yeah and that's like how do you how do
you how do you you know convince someone
the worst thing about it is it's the
other stuff China does like the weaker
camps yeah at what point do we have to
do something does the international
community have to do something honestly
don't know it's not like you know we can
sanction a lot of countries yeah but we
can't really do that with China's too
big well there's something you said the
other day I think it was like a couple
weeks ago and you're saying like if
their economy does crumble they have two
options ask for help or go to war yeah
right if it really is crumbling and now
I mean there's weren't they like making
threats I mean yeah sorry well so what
was it what was that EMP thing was that
did you pull that yeah yeah yeah it was
a something about them like saying well
if you come into our
our waters we're gonna EMP your ships
that waters they're basically claiming
are there they're stealing yeah exactly
but it's like they're almost looking for
any excuse yeah you know like I dare you
come into our waters did I think those
are our waters even though they're not
right
I think we're dangerously close to an
actual full on conflict yeah I think so
I think a lot of you know a lot of
people haven't been paying attention to
the stuff that's been happening over the
past several years I bring it up often
when I was working for a fusion there
was there was a team of journalists
there that were mighty nice a team but
as a couple they were investigating the
Nicaraguan canal
now this collapsed but basically you had
Chinese interests didn't want to pay for
the Panama Canal but that that Canal is
its beastman yeah you want to draw it
you want it you want to bring your butt
all the way around South America or you
want to cut through the middle right so
they're like how much will it cost it
just digs straight through Nicaragua and
that would have essentially drained one
of the largest freshwater sources in
Central America they're like we don't
care we want to get our boats the other
side yeah so I guess the project fell
through but they've been doing these
things that undermining auspice exactly
yeah like it doesn't make sense to make
a new canal that would go through
Nicaragua Nicaragua which is like
ridiculously long relative to Panama
right they didn't care they said light
it up dump the money so they but they do
crazy things to manipulate their
currencies to scan the system they steal
our IP right now is the craziest thing
they've been secretly giving money to
academics to steal our research well I'm
there these academics there and on the
take they don't report they don't they
lie to the feds yep yeah dude we're
dangerously close I don't think people
realize at a certain point so so here's
you know here's my worst case kind of
vision of what we have China's economy
took a major major hit and so did ours
yeah and that's like that's the fallout
from something we can't necessarily
control but China was lying about it now
we're gonna see you know Trump just
invoked the defense production act which
means he can seize basically the whole
economy this isn't this is a crazy man
the defense production act basically
means he can set prices set wages he
just doomed boom do it huh yeah yeah a
lot of power I mean it's it's it's a
wartime event right yeah so what happens
now that we're taking all of this stuff
away from China
they were undermining us they were
taking manufacturing that was building
up their economy we take it all back
then what they get desperate they get
angry yeah facing collapse you know it's
possible the rich people in China just
bow out but I gotta imagine there's some
people in that government are gonna be
alike no way I'm not giving it up yeah
and I'll take it by force so I think you
know what you end up seeing is I don't
think you'll see China you know senemo
to you boats to our shores and then
storm the beaches of you know San Diego
or something yeah but what you will see
is them increasing their push on the
South China Sea into other regions doing
underhanded deals with other countries
that we've sanctioned and then
eventually it's that point where World
War 3 yeah yeah because like imagine you
have the South China Sea let's say China
start saying you know what you you like
the more we isolate our economies this
is this is one of the ideas that you
know I don't necessarily wanna use the
word globalist but there are people who
had this political theory that if you
create free trade you will force
economic trade lines that both countries
will resist being broken you know so
which which prevents war so if we had
say the TPP with China and all of our
manufacturing is over there war would be
very difficult because it's supposed to
be reciprocal right but it wasn't so I
don't know I don't want to pretend like
I know what the plan was a lot he's
publishing his head but there's
something that been talked about if you
get trade line between the countries
both sides of an interest in not going
to war but what happens when China
controls it's all one-sided and they're
getting everything from it and just
extracting your labor and siphon it away
what happens when you cut that off it's
like taking away the the drug from the
addict yeah basically so I don't know
you know flashing their income it's like
I don't want that and they'll go back to
being a regional power so I don't know
man I don't look I don't think we're
necessarily you know like days away from
something like that
yeah but what happens if they're like
now that we're not getting business we
have to step things up or they do blow
up one of our ships that crosses it
they've already laser a remember water
remember we talked about this right they
lasered one of our planes right so I
don't know if that was a scanning thing
yeah
and so the US was like hey don't do that
mm-hmm
man Americans still want to go to war
you know I mean no I wanted one of the
challenges of any democratic system
they're not saying we're not a democracy
where constitutional republic but we use
democratic institutions to send
representatives to Washington with
represent representative government it
is very very difficult to go to war
China war yeah totalitarian state
exactly easy yep I made and they go to
war with us it'll be pretty easy to go
okay we're going to war with you yeah
yeah I mean you'd be surprised man yeah
so I'm I don't know like all of my World
War two history but I remember reading
that they were like anti World War two
protesters they were like we should not
enter you know we should not intervene
and stuff and they were protesting that
we're going over there you know you know
the really crazy thing about military
and stuff is that people don't seem to
realize how powerful a single individual
with a gun is there and it goes two ways
right so you'll talk to these people a
lot of like I guess you know more urban
types okay
uneducated non military you know no
experience and they'll say things like
no one will go to war with us we've got
you know aircraft carriers and Scud
missiles and blah blah blah and it's
like what is that gonna do we're gonna
level a few city blocks we're gonna have
air superiority there's a good things
don't get me wrong but you know you got
to watch out because some of these
countries have more manpower than we do
and you can't occupy a city a street a
street corner with a scud missile yeah
or I don't even know the use of Scud
missiles I don't know it's just blank so
that that's one of the funny arguments
about you know that the gun control
groups is that you know if you're really
gonna go up against the government they
got missiles and it's like so why did we
lose in Afghanistan and Vietnam maybe a
bunch of farmers with guns dude come on
man yeah the point is you get a bunch of
angry people with weapons and you can
actually you ever play commando conquer
a little bit yeah
or the original Warcraft yeah you know
you know my strategy always was send it
over right away I just pump out grunts
mass produce low-level cop combatants
and then just keep sending them in waves
non-stop and you in his overwhelming
with little dude
skill they're peon that was actually I
think what Russia did in World War two
they instead of making good tanks
they're like let's make tons of pretty
really bed tanks and then they just wave
after wave of really awful tanks and you
know it reminds me of Futurama
I love the feature I'm references by the
way when's that Brannigan's like I sent
wave after wave of my own men until we
reached the kill bot limit and they shut
down that's how we won the war oh yeah
yeah but you know in this regard if if
China ends up you know if we really went
into a war with them I'm pretty sure
they're standing army is bigger than
ours but we do have technological
superiority big time I don't know man
although they have been stealing our IP
so yep that'll be fun stealing our
technology and stuff I guess it's called
Zerg rush Zerg can you do that that's
what everyone's saying
really Tim Zerg rush yeah no it is I
guess so wave after wave I remember when
I first started playing like command &
Conquer hmm and I'm like you got to
upgrade your science and then you got to
make special you know get the Tiberium
and then you make special robots and
make the better guys and then my friend
actually showed me it was like not just
looking just like spamming it and just
like making a bunch of what are they
call GIS or as it's been decades since
I've been a long time
although command & Conquer came out with
a mobile game recently it's pretty fun
is it yeah it's not bad I'm cool man
it's pretty good yeah so what do you
think man where we where we at so far
yeah it's it's getting the point they've
18 states have deployed the National
Guard really yeah 18 states watching say
it's 1,500 Guardsmen there's talk of the
army
I mean look they just deployed the Navy
to New York mom Trump's got the ability
to snap his fingers and increase the
minimum wage yeah but will he do it not
probably not probably not I wonder what
he will do though I mean yeah yeah like
what the what is this defense act really
gonna miss I've not been good at
predicting the future so I have no idea
oh man you know you know what's
interesting a lot of people a lot of
Trump supporters are saying that this is
bad for the president a lot of ways but
I'm like I don't think so
don't see that at all yeah especially if
he comes out on top of this if he comes
out on top and this ends in two months
in the markets skyrockets and he's like
saved the day yeah dude it's gonna be
you're gonna see people who you never
thought being like oh I was wrong about
him but it's not just that
they're shut down the Canadian border oh
yeah it's like like Donald Donald
Trump's always talking about you know
immigration and we got to get a hold on
immigration and stuff it's like
congratulations because the cordilla
virus boom we shut everything down yeah
every got what he wanted
yeah and now he has direct control over
the economy he's gonna be able to just
snap his fingers and get a lot done that
he wanted to do without without any
impedance no that's true and who's gonna
argue if he right now is likely more
funding for the wall they're gonna be
like okay because what's the alternative
everyone's closing their borders yeah
this is great Guatemala said we're not
allowed in no Americans oh really
yeah dude this is the end of like at
least the time being globalization yeah
there's not they're not gonna I mean
this is the time to to put a hold on it
but I hope it doesn't end you know it's
not gonna well what we want to avoid is
authoritarianism but I think Trump is
gonna get everything he wants he doesn't
want a bad economy but now he's gonna
have the powers to just do things
without sudden standing in his way
that's right and if and and and we're at
a point now where we're dealing with
this national emergency like this is the
craziest thing I've ever experienced we
can't we're not supposed to go outside
right now I mean we probably could but
we might get in trouble yeah New York
has announced they're gonna be doing a
there you know get ready because a
shelter-in-place order is coming soon
really yeah and they already did it in
San Francisco where you can get in
trouble if you leave your house in
France you need a letter from the
government to leave your own house I've
never seen it this crazy in my life Wow
so so that so think about how bad it is
what would happen if Trump right now
said Mexico has been slammed this is
true by the international community for
doing nothing about the coronavirus the
president is still doing big rallies he
doesn't like all the time where he goes
out and he hugs people and kisses them
oh my god there was like a video of him
like biting him on the cheek playfully
seriously yeah and the people in the
country are like now we're fine no I
don't worry about it it's like we're
good they're not cancelling any big
events so now Trump is gonna know now if
Trump came out and said they're not
taking the coronavirus seriously we need
to get this wall done yeah who would
dare oppose him
I mean no one just makes sense you see
you'd see some people I mean yeah but it
feels like the majority of people are
like maybe we should have that wall now
no no no there's still the stupid people
on Twitter I mean saying things like a
wall can't stop a virus because the
virus is literally walking through the
border and I expected a fence to stop
them you know it's because people carry
the virus I just imagined a cartoon of
it you ever see that what is that I
can't think of the name of the movie but
there's this movie where these little
little fur balls with like teeth it's
like a horror film and when they get
together they create a bigger ball and
they just like mow people down what's
that video game where you do that man I
can't remember the name of that movie a
bit what's that video game where you
roll the ball full of big things the the
better analogy is the Simpsons reference
where the doctors try to explain to mr.
burns why he can't get sick remember and
he's a little door and he's like look at
these oversized novelty germs and he
smashes he tries to get him all to go in
you don't remember that he's like and
then he does the Three Stooges thing
yeah what did he call it I don't know I
don't remember but that's what people so
anyway critters thank you thank you all
the comments are screaming critters yes
barriers back to the more serious thanks
everybody thanks no I just I'm just
thinking like if it came out right now
look these stories about Mexico not
taking it seriously art you know getting
decent shares so if Trump came out and
said in order to secure the country from
the threat of the corona virus we're
gonna be expanding production on the
border wall yeah he'd have some
detractors but a lot of people would
shut up a lot of a lot of people there's
a lot of like mainstream personalities
that are like Fairweather anti-trump
errs okay that it's it's really like
it's like I was saying that it's really
easy to hate the president when you're
in a safety net when you're in the
safety net but now that you have like
this the moderates of this country
regular Americans saying just to keep me
safe mm-hmm now you see Joe Scarborough
bill I support the president yeah right
you see Danna bad yeah so so well their
reaction is based on the fact that they
don't want to defy what they think the
general public wants
so if Trump now says I know a lot of
people have you know
questions and criticisms about this but
you have to understand what Mexico has
been doing they've been not taking this
seriously and we need to get these
numbers down yeah they're gonna shut up
they're not gonna they're not gonna say
anything
yeah as you know because there's nothing
to be gained by coming out and saying no
no security it would almost be like and
this is actually worrisome to me if this
if this continues with no one you know
putting a check on like government
authority then you're gonna have people
being scared to question what Trump is
doing because it's for national security
right yeah so what happens when this all
winds down well hopefully it goes back
to normal yeah what's in this what's in
this coronavirus bailout bill it's like
300 billion dollars for small business
loans it's just so massive isn't it
almost a trillion dollars things like
1.5 - yeah yeah 1.4 or something so what
is it what's the national debt 21 22
some ridiculous yeah it's alright so
what's what's another trillion is
helping the the regular people you know
yeah small businesses they doesn't ever
end you don't does it ever though I mean
that's like the headline of this bill so
if it is dude like the Patriot Act until
they dare impose until they slip in all
the random things have nothing to do
anything else and that's that's that's
the history of this country man it's
ridiculous they're gonna it's literally
the Patriot Act they give it this fancy
name and say would you vote against this
massive thing no one has read yeah so I
think what Rand Paul did he vote no on
this I believe so I'm willing to bet
Rand Paul that I would place he takes
after his dad doctor no Conger so he
just vote to no one everything FEV if we
you know I respect that if we don't know
what it is you know I'm not gonna vote
for it yeah make sense any but I do if
they're gonna spend a bunch of money
he's gonna vote no what they're saying
now it's gonna be like a thousand bucks
in April and May what's that gonna do
man yeah thousand bucks per person
that's not enough I mean some there's
some hippie living in the farm is gonna
be cool and there's gonna be some do
with a kid being like oh my gosh yeah
man what am I suppose to do about this
yeah he did
against it no imagine we did vote
against yeah no I don't blame him I like
Rand Paul thanks for checking out this
segment from the Tim cast IRL podcast we
do the show every Monday through Friday
at 8 p.m. sometimes an hour or two and
we do have a full live recorded version
of the show that includes a lot of
comments and smaller segments you
probably don't see if you want to check
that out you can watch live at 8 p.m.
Monday through Friday or become a member
of this channel and for five bucks a
month you get full access to all of the
recorded podcasts every day after the
show we make them available in the
community section of this YouTube
channel so don't forget to subscribe and
stick around for more segments and more
shows Monday through Friday at 8 p.m.
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all in the next show
you